Pour ne louper aucune vidéo,
abonnez-vous etactiver la petite cloche.
Attention !
1, 2, 3 !
Pourquoi fait-on des crêpes
à la chandeleur ?
Je suis tout retourné.
C'est une fête à la fois
païenne et chrétienne.
Àl'origine, il y a la fête
aux flambeaux.
Organisée avant le printemps
chez les celtes et chezles romains
pour célébrer le retour de la lumière
après de longs mois d'hiver.
Mais c'estaussi
dans la religion chrétienne
le moment où l'on célèbre
un événement particulier.
La venuede Jésus
au temple de Jérusalem.
Pour fêter cet épisode, le pape Serge premiers,
en fonctionau VIIème siècle,
décide d'organiser des processions
avec des pèlerins portant des cierges.
La "festa candelarum" comme il l'appelle,
la fête des chandelles.
"chandelle" à l'origine du mot chandeleur.
Et les crêpes dans tout ça ?
Vous connaissez la recette,
300 g de farine, 3 œufs entiers,
3 cuillères àsoupe de sucre, 2 d'huile,
50 g de beurre fondu et 60 cl de sel.
Allez, une larme de rhum.
Ce sont des ingrédients
à la portée de tous.
À l'origine, les crêpes étaient
cuisinées par lespaysans.
Une façon de montrer qu'ils avaient
encore de quoi manger après l'hiver.
Par ailleurs, la formeet la couleur des crêpes
évoque le soleil et donc le retour du printemps.
D'après une légende, réussir
à faire sauter une crêpe
de la main droite, en tenant une pièce d'or
de la main gauche, porte bonheur.
À mon avis, avec un euro,
ça devrait marcher aussi.
Ça marche !
Je suis heureux !
si vous avezaimé cette vidéo,
n'hésitez pas à laisser un pouce bleu.
Merci les Épicurieux !
Pour les plus gourmands
en voici d'autres,
ett pour ne rien rater
abonnez-vous et activer la cloche !
oh